hey there guys so today I just wanted to
share with you my latest outdoor gym
type thing so the idea is that it's a
predominantly bodyweight gym I wanted it
to be outdoors and my reasons for this
firstly are that as many of you know my
wife now expecting actually the due date
is today and when the baby comes I'm
anticipating it's gonna be a little
harder for me to get to the gym so I
thought I'd go about creating something
I could train with here at home having
something outdoors like this just giving
me a spacewalk and come and work out
really quickly get a proper burn going
because you know where they put up asset
at Rabaul like this I can launch off the
plyometric stuff I've got some power
left down there which I'll show you in a
moment
at the same time I've been doing lots of
videos on things like Spartan training
and wim HOF and those guys all train
outdoors I've talked about how that
helps to kind of harden you up and
reverse some of the sort of
domestication maybe it'll toughen up my
immune system help my general cold
tolerance we shall see so in order to
adapt to changing circumstances I'm
changing up my workout routine basically
I'm going from Batman style training to
Nightwing style training it's very easy
if you've got a garden to set up a cool
bodyweight setup as I'm gonna show you
here the cool thing is as well that this
whole thing would cost you maybe 150
quid max and you can get a really good
workout here I mean you don't need
anything else so this is the bio arena
so first things first according s is
here the chin upper bar obviously you
know what that is you can use it for
pull-ups or chin-ups at the same time
I've got some additional appendages here
I've attached this which I can sometimes
grip onto and use for pull-ups I also
use this if you've seen any of my other
videos for overcoming isometrics
particularly pecs so after I've done a
PEC routine I'll try and squeeze this
together as hard as I can
great for muscle fiber recruitment grip
strength etc I've also
hung a rope here attached with two
carabiners the safety and using a rope
which costs like 20 30 quid on ebay I
think less than that even you can add a
whole bunch of possible exercises
obviously rope climbing is fantastic for
grip strength it's also one of the best
ways to build bicep strength and that's
one of the reasons the gymnasts have
such big biceps are so simply by buying
a rope you can massively increase the
range of possibilities for your pull-up
bar when you start out you'll find that
it's not the biceps that give out first
rather your grip but by using other
exercises like bodyweight skull crushers
or like bodyweight rows where you're
only using half of your weight you can
toughen up the grip and the forum
strength and then you could build up to
doing lots of rope climbs you can also
hold yourself in position there's lots
of things you can do get a rope it's
great and one more thing you can hang
for me chin up bar is gymnastics rings
don't get TRX
TRX is a ripoff it costs hundreds of
pounds gymnastic rings for twenty third
we'll do all the same stuff but at the
same time dips and things because you
can put your weight onto the Rings I
can't quite do a muscle up on there yet
because it's a weird grip for me the too
narrow or too wide but I realize that's
something that I can overcome with
training so that's another goal I'm
working towards down here we have some
parallettes again these are like twenty
thirty quid and using these you can
perform all kinds of hand balancing
exercises things like handstand push-ups
things like planche things like VESA
else it all that stuff and they're
incredibly versatile with those and with
the pull-up bar you've got all of your
push and pull exercises covered terms of
core work everything you need really
i've also they've got a kettlebell
kettlebells obviously aren't
particularly for bodyweight training but
it they're very useful for general
functional training because you're
training at different angles having to
cope and deal with the momentum this
makes them the perfect fit for the same
kind of training where you're building
funk
explosive nightwing style strength at
the same time you can use something like
this this is a big kettlebell at waist
36 kilograms you can use that for a
whole bunch of additional things for
instance you can use it to do weighted
pistol squats actually think that
kettlebells are one of the best way to
Train if you're struggling to do leg
work at home because whilst getting a
barbell could be expensive with enough
weight and also take up hollow space a
kettlebell is relatively small and easy
to move around relatively affordable but
you can still do all the things like
squats goblet squats straight legged
deadlift deadlift clean and press all
that stuff and all just this with this
one item that will fit neatly into the
corner of a room that said I do also
have a barbell and my last item here a
battle rake which I attached to this
ladder that has been randomly living
here for an awfully long time battle
ropes are fantastic for resistance
cardio will burn more calories more
quickly by combining something that
taxes the muscle as well as the
cardiovascular system and at the same
time you'll be toning up your shoulders
and yeah battle ropes are fantastic
these are a bit light but again very
cheap and you'll be able to fit it into
a garden or taking me to a park lap
around a tree those are possibilities
the barbell on the other hand I just
used for curls I can also use the
kettlebell here curls it's also useful
for tons more leg exercises and compound
movements I do have a bit more weight in
the shed but this is a good amount to
leave it on I like to just have
everything ready to go something doesn't
grab it I've been using it for lots of
those old time strongman lifts that I've
talked about in a previous video that
again challenge you to kind of control
the weight and use your whole body in a
more explosive manner so basically the
takeaways are if your lifestyles about
to change in a drastic way then mixing
up your training methods your training
regime can be a smart strategy if you're
training from home then doing bodyweight
stuff primarily is an excellent option
I'm gonna be doing this now a few times
a week and hopefully still getting to
the gym once a week at least on the
Mondays when I work on the bar near to
do heavy compound lifts bag work that
kind of things I also punch this rope
for kind of target practice but
it's not the same and then that's how
I'm gonna be changing my workout routine
for me Batman style to a Nightwing style
and I'll be sharing the full Nightwing
training program here on the channel
very soon I hope that this outdoor setup
has given you some ideas some
inspiration some different ways to train
and yeah whilst my uploading schedule
might be a little bit more hit and miss
at the moment I've got a kind of backlog
of content I've made so they'll still be
stuff come to the channel and I'll be
back very soon hopefully with some body
weight skills and a different kind of
strength to talk about so that will
sounds good then I'll see you next time
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now
you